- [Narrator] We have the
graph of three functions here.
And we're told that one
of them is the function F,
one is its' first derivative,
and then one of them is the
second derivative.
We just don't know which one is which.
And so, like always, pause
this video and see if you
can figure it out.
Alright, now the way I'm
going to tackle it is
I'm gonna look at each of these graphs and
try to think, what would
their derivatives look like.
So for this first one,
we can see our derivative
right over here, our
slope of our tangent line.
It would be a little bit
negative and then it gets more
and more and more negative,
and as we approach this vertical
asymptote, right over here,
it looks like it's
approaching negative infinity.
So, the derivative would
actually, over here,
it would be a little bit less than zero,
but then it would get more
and more and more negative
and then it would approach
negative infinity.
So, it would have a similar
shape, general shape,
to the graph itself, at
least to the left of this
vertical asymptote.
Now, what about to the right
of the vertical asymptote?
Right to the right of the
vertical asymptote it looks like
the slope of the tangent line
is very negative, but then
it becomes less and
less and less negative,
and it looks like it is
approaching, it is approaching zero.
So, on this side the derivative
starts out super negative
and then it looks like it is
the derivative is going to
asymptote towards zero,
something like that.
So, based on what I just sketched,
it looks like this right
graph is a good candidate
for the derivative of this left graph.
You might say, what's
wrong with this blue graph?
Well this blue graph out here,
notice that it's positive.
So if this were the
derivative of the left graph,
then that means the left graph
would need a positive slope
out here, but it doesn't
have a positive slope.
It's a slightly negative
slope becoming super negative.
And so, right here we're slightly negative
and then we become very negative.
And so maybe this is,
let's call this F,
and maybe this is F prime.
This is F prime right over here.
And now, let's look at this middle graph.
What would its derivative do?
So over here, our slope
is slightly negative,
and then it becomes more
and more and more and more
and more negative.
And so the derivative
of this might look like,
it has to be slightly negative,
but then it gets more and more
and more and more negative
as we approach that vertical asymptote.
And then on the right side
of the vertical asymptote,
our derivative is very positive here,
and then it gets less and
less and less and less
and less and less positive.
And so, we start our derivative
would be very positive
and then it would get
less and less and less
and less positive.
It looks like it might,
the slope might asymptoting
towards zero, so our graph
might look something like that.
Well the left graph right here
looks a lot like what I just sketched out
as a candidate derivative
for this blue graph,
for this middle graph.
And so I would say that this is F,
then this is the derivative of that,
which would make it F prime
and then we already established
that this right graph is the
derivative of the left one,
so if it's the derivative of F prime,
it's not F prime itself,
it's the second derivative.
So I feel pretty good about that.
And just for good measure,
we could think about
what the derivative of
this graph would look like.
Here the slope is slightly negative,
but then it gets more and more
and more and more and more
negative, so the derivative
would have a similar shape here.
And then here, our derivative
would be very positive,
and it gets less and
less and less and less
and less positive.
And so, we start very
positive and then it gets less
and less and less and
less and less positive.
And so as a general shape, it
actually does look a lot like
this first graph.
But the reason why I'm not
gonna say that this first graph
is the derivative of the right hand graph,
is because this right hand graph
was the only good candidate
that we had for the derivative
of the left hand graph.
And so I feel pretty good
with what we selected,
that this middle one is F, the left one
is the first derivative, and the right one
is the second derivative.